there is nothing that enrages me more
than fat models I don't like the
celebration of morbid obesity you're
okay and the skin that you're in this
dress is everything just don't see that
getting better do something about it I
am fact the fact that I have rolls on my
belly doesn't make me any less of a
human being
[Music]
the reason I am here is because I feel
like in the past fad has been such like
like derogatory term and like we've been
so like ridiculed for the way we look
it's almost like I want to take that
word back and make it a positive thing
like someone called me fat oh he's so
negative and be like yes I am you know
what I mean just like change the way we
think of it a lot of words it should
offend me don't I think it's because I'm
just kind of like I don't even need the
words you know your intention exactly I
know your intention and if you're using
it to like hurt me I don't care what
word to use I care that you wanted to
hurt me I just don't look at like a word
like that as being like you don't want
to give it power no I don't want to give
it weight yeah
[Music]
I'm only standing on this one and not
strongly disagree because some people do
like try to be plus-sized like there's
like lots of people in the gay community
that are called like eaters and feeders
so people do try to be bigger but I mean
I don't think it's necessarily a choice
so that's one reason why I'm not I lost
60 pounds in six months everyone was so
happy for me I hated myself I hated the
way I looked I hated why I did why I
exercise and things like that and so I
made the conscious decision
of my parents are not going to be
supportive or maybe they won't like it
my community the Korean community is
gonna be really disappointed that
there's a fat Korean walking around the
world but it was a choice for me to say
well I don't want to work out eight
hours a day every day and hate what I
look like to be skinnier so I'm gonna
let myself eat more than 1/4 cup of
white rice today I disagree because I
believe in society especially in America
we have this idea that oh yeah all fat
people ate themselves that way that they
just sit at home and they're lazy and
they don't do anything and they ate
themselves that way but they don't take
into account people who have a disease
they don't take into account people who
work out and their body is just built
that way so there are all of these other
factors that the average person who's
judging people don't take into account
and they just look at someone they say
oh you're fat and you're not doing
anything about it but I also want to
throw out there like it is possible that
people have eaten themselves to that
point but then you look at like why did
that happen like there's trauma there's
rough coping mechanisms there's so many
different things that can lead to
somebody resorting to that and then
eating themselves into this situation
because I know that's what happened to
me I didn't choose it but it happened
when I first went back to Korea which is
like the country of my parents and like
it was amazing for me and I was like wow
I look like everyone else right like
this is my home country this is supposed
to be my place it's not my place cuz I'm
fat and so walking down the street
people are like do you know how easy it
is for you to get liposuction here
they won't even scar cuz they can do it
pretty for an Asian person whatever I
had family said you know what we'll fix
your ears we'll fix your nose we'll fix
your eyes your lips and all your fat and
that is just it's mind-boggling to me
that you would even think to offer that
or think that I dislike my body and I
think that's also the thing the critique
comes from this idea of you must hate
how you look so let me help you I think
everyone in this entire room has for
their body like it doesn't really matter
what size you are you could be the
skinniest girl in the world you're gonna
be called like a fat [ __ ] like if you
think that this is like exempt from you
because we're bigger or we have
different body types like you know we've
all been changed for our bodies people
feel that they have the right to come up
to you and impose their views on to you
about your personal body the fact that I
have roles on my belly and big thighs
doesn't make me any less of a human
being my body is not for you I didn't
ask you
that's it
[Music]
the reason why I hesitated so much is
because I will love the way I look no
matter what at the same time like if I
like was to keep dancing and keep going
to the gym and all this and then I just
like happened to lose weight like I'd
also be like cool I'll just let myself
no matter what is pretty much what I'm
saying
I want to be here because this is like
the work that I do and I like doing this
it's gonna like make it's like being
here someone's gonna say something to me
and be like oh like like you weren't
provide positivity you weren't prepared
to visit um you want collaboration but
let us but has the things with anybody
else besides me I think like if I if I
say this and I'm not saying nothing else
myself is saying like you know what
sometimes I do think about losing weight
because I do and like and like everyone
does because there's privileges when
you're smaller so it's like it's natural
to think I want to be smaller because
there's so many more options to me if
I'm smaller but I don't want to lose
weight
for me um since I am a dancer it is the
most annoying thing like I go to
auditions and I'm the only like
plus-sized person there and literally if
you go to a concert and see an artist
you will like never see someone that
looks like me dancing back up for like
Chris Brown all they care about is you
know sex sells and you know plus-size
isn't sexy which it is obviously but
they don't they can't get that you know
out of their heads that skinny is like
the like top - you're like life so what
kept you though from on the strongly
agree a big choice the world is created
with smaller bodies in mind like
everything we experience when you sit in
a folding chair when you go on an
airplane when you go to the movie
theater and the unfortunate truth is our
population is not that small so just
like organically speaking smaller people
have bigger privileges because the
world's designed like for them I had to
quit a whole career because of my size
like I got my first degree in musical
theater performance I was ready to go to
Broadway and then through college I
gained 65 pounds and not only did I
watch my professors lose interest in me
but I watched casting people lose
interest in me and that's how I ended up
in education because I want to teach
that that's not okay you can play any
role because that's what's baffling to
me is that we're in an age where in
theatre we can suspend our disbelief
that like animals can talk and things
like that but we can't accept that a
plus-sized person could have somebody
fall in love with them unless it's
hairspray I guess the only story we get
and that's infuriating
I love my body but it took a lot of time
to get there when I graduated college
and I was in like the biggest place that
I've ever been I was in a depression
that I can't even like begin to explain
about it and then when I went off to
grad school I was like something has to
change new city new me and so I got up
every morning and I looked in the mirror
and I was like what can I like about
myself today and I learned how to just
love every little part of me because it
is mine it belongs to me and if I don't
love it who is going to so what keeps
you there that it took so much time to
get there mm-hmm and being plus-size I
don't love it I don't hate it it's here
for me and it's got me this far it's
sabotage me in a lot of ways and that's
that's his own journey I just think for
like a lot of like younger folks like
when I was your age or younger people
said either hate your body or love your
body I wasn't either way and I was in
the middle and so you feel so stuck and
so you feel so alone and it's this idea
of it's okay if you don't love your body
it's okay if you're not obsessed with it
just be kind to yourself and that's
that's good enough if you can be kind to
your best friend you can be kind to
yourself and so that's that is why I am
here
every morning I'll wake up and I will
like get out of bed and I'll look in the
mirror now I would really just like I
was like I like a broad like my chest
like with my stomach all they shake my
ass is like guys like like I want to
like shower myself with love every day
and that's like really important to me
to myself the time to be like oh I
appreciate my body for it does for me
like do I want to change sometimes sure
will it maybe it will maybe it won't but
like I've been day like I will love it
regardless because it is like a home for
me and my soul
[Music]
good humans thanks for sticking around
so if you guys want to receive a mystery
gift box from us in the next week let us
know why you love spectrum so much in a
letter to Jubilee send it to this P o
box and that's where we're gonna be
getting them we read through everything
that you send us so thank you and we
hope to hear from you guys soon
for now make sure you like subscribe
leave a comment below follow us on
Instagram all that jazz and we'll see
you next time